former WWE wrestler Sarah Weston better
known as Sarah Lee has died the Tough
Enough season six winner was just 30
years old
[Music]
[Applause]
now the match is over and I'm still just
so excited and my adrenaline's just
rushing everything went well me and
Amanda didn't forget any of the moves
and the crowd was cheering like I was
just cheesing just couldn't stop smiling
Sarah's mother Terry Lee confirmed her
death on Facebook writing quote it is
with heavy hearts we wanted to share
that our Sarah Weston has gone to be
with Jesus we are all in shock and
arrangements are not complete we ask
that you respectfully let our family
mourn we all need prayers especially
Corey and her children and just two days
before the post Sarah shared this selfie
celebrating being quote healthy enough
to hit the gym two days in a row her
cause of death hasn't been revealed at
this time fellow wrestler aims organize
a GoFundMe campaign to raise money for
Sarah's memorial fund
[Applause]
and she earned a one-year contract with
WWE after winning WWE's Tough Enough in
2015. and the newest WWE Diva
is Sara Lee is the winner
Sarah married fellow WWE wrestler Corey
James Weston in 2017 and had three
children together
[Music]